alors il y a un gamin qui s'approche de
sa grand-mère et qui lui dit mamie mamie
chérie que j'adore je peux t'amener le
fusil de papy
mais mon petit chéri pourquoi est-ce que
tu m'amènerais le fusil de papier moi tu
sais bien que je ne sais pas m'en servir
et puis je suis beaucoup trop vieille
pour pour apprendre non c'est pas pour
que tu t'en sers c'est pour que tu le
mettes à côté de toi ah bon mais quel
drôle d'idée pourquoi veux-tu que je le
mette à côté de moi et ben parce que
papa nous a dit la dernière fois quand
mamie passera l'arme à gauche je vous
inviterai tous à Eurodisney
[Applaudissements]
ma Cécile de Ménibus qu'on retrouve tous
les jours de 17h à 20h sur Sud Radio
dans l'émission les vraies voies avec
Philippe tu es excellente merci Monsieur
très souvent bravo Macha oui merci
je la trouve très mignonne quand j'étais
petit j'ai appris que la chatte était
une la femelle du chat la chienne celle
du chien une [ __ ] servait à amarrer les
bateaux les boules étaient toujours
accompagnées du cochonnet qu'une pipe se
fume que le 69 n'était qu'un chiffre et
depuis tout est parti en couille
[Applaudissements]
elisabethier
s
le président de la République et la
tradition veut que elle escort elle
vient chercher le président français à
la gare en carrosse et il remonte jusque
Buckingham Palace il s'installe dans la
voiture la reine fait signe et un moment
donné
flatulence énorme dans des chevaux dans
des chevaux ça pète
ça sent énormément c'est une vraie
histoire ça c'est vrai histoire c'est
une vraie histoire alors la reine a été
habituée elle continue à saluer elle dit
Mr President je suis désolé monsieur le
Président et Jacques Chirac la regarde
pas de problème j'ai cru que c'était un
cheval votre Magister
son livre est meilleur
[Applaudissements]
pour lui parce qu'il faudrait pas
l'enfoncer
Gilles mon Gilles une petite dernière
pour la fin c'est un journaliste de TF1
qui veut faire un petit reportage encore
ça à l'époque de Jean-Pierre Pernaut lui
fait un gros bisou et donc et donc le
mec va encore dans un tout petit village
entre la mer et la montagne magnifique
et rencontre un vieux un vieux un vieux
maire tu vois le mec 95 ans tu vois et
voilà et donc il a le reportage et
Monsieur Rossi il s'appelle aussi
monsieur Rossi on va faire un petit
reportage sur vous ça va être magnifique
on va mettre en valeur votre village et
tout donc je vais vous poser des
questions allez-y on y va les gars c'est
parti allez première question monsieur
Rossi en tant que maire de votre petit
village en Corse quel est votre meilleur
souvenir
mon meilleur souvenir j'avais une
biquetteurs chercher à Fontaine chercher
partout on trouvait pas la biquette ah
bon et alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
un jour on a retrouvé la biquette elle
était perdue dans le boss et alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait la fête à
la petite fontaine
tout le monde était pété ah d'accord et
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors on
a pris la biquette et on a [ __ ] la
biquette comme ça
arrêtez non excusez-moi les gros refait
non non non on refait on refait les gars
bon là on l'a refait monsieur aussi
en tant que mère de votre petit village
encore ce qu'elle est quel est votre
plume votre meilleur souvenir voilà et
votre meilleur souvenir
[Rires]
quel est votre plus mauvais souvenir le
plus mauvais souvenir
c'est quand je me suis perdu dans le
boss
[Applaudissements]
es
qui discutent et ils passent en question
à son ami lui dit est-ce que toi tu
crois la vie après la mort et son ami il
lui dit ah non pas du tout et toi bah
avant j'y croyais pas mais depuis que ma
belle-mère est morte je revis
merci ma Carla merci bon Samuel oui
à Tunis
de Tunis il vient d'ouvrir le stand et
toute la Tunisie vient pour manger ses
boulettes un jour il rencontre une meuf
et il tombe amoureux mais il apprend que
le père de cette filière radiologue donc
ça fout la fout mal de dire qu'il est
vendeurs de boulettes il dit moi je suis
pharmacien j'ai quelques pharmacies à
Tunis le lendemain la fille elle est
avec des copines elle a dit meuf il y a
un mec il a ouvert des boulettes un
petit stand de boulettes faut vraiment
qu'on y aille et ils vont avec les
copines elle est le mec il est de dos
comme ça et la fièvre est bonjour
monsieur je peux avoir ciboulette il
fait ciboulette tout de suite il connaît
comme ça il voit sa meufs alors ça sera
deux matins de midi et deux soirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]